[Música]
hola qué tal con esta guitarra de fondo
les habla pablo gómez barrios y es un
gran placer estar con todos ustedes hoy
en la represa cibernética con leonora
chapman grupo valencia y leonardo gimeno
les presentamos el castor cibernético de
este viernes 2 de noviembre en vivo y en
directo por facebook live youtube y en
nuestro sitio
rcn puntos ya y un caluroso saludo a
todos los que nos están escuchando y
oyendo allá del otro lado del ojo de la
cámara y gracias por su agradable
sintonía leonora rufo leonardo
bienvenidos muchas gracias a todos
nuestros amigos un saludo a todo el
mundo como se han dado cuenta ustedes ya
quien estudio ya ha notado la presencia
de nuestro invitado de hoy
javier rojas guitarrista mexicano que se
encuentra de paso de visita aquí en
montreal vamos a conversar con él en el
transcurso del programa bienvenido
javier muchas gracias muchas gracias
gracias por escucharnos todo el público
que está desde su aparato receptor y un
placer pues tenerte aquí con nosotros
hasta vamos a conversar de la razón de
tu visita aquí en montreal mientras que
nos arrollan con la guitarra como decía
al principio nos encanta eso no nos
sucede muy a menudo leonora que nos
apoyen con guitarra cuando estamos en el
programa excelente idea aquí en el
castor cibernético pues entonces
arrullados nos dejamos no habla de ruido
me acuerdo del ente que habla del
arrullo puneño cuando le canta la
canción a don rodrigo de carreras pero
es un poquito más intenso que la
guitarra hermosa que está de fondo aquí
ya no pero la guitarra de javier se ha
poner intensa ahorita también nada más
que brava arrulla más nada más porque
estamos nosotros acá pero antes de darle
rienda
suelta a este castor mensajero no sé si
ustedes tienen algo por ahí insólito o
alguna noticia que les haya llamado la
atención a mí me sigue llamando la
atención la de la de la caravana de
migrantes
así eeuu y que el presidente de eeuu
ponga está tan tan enfermo que pone todo
lo que puede en contra de esa caravana
de 4000 personas que van a buscar un
futuro y dijo que si los dos caminantes
le tiran piedras al ejército el ejército
puede disparar sí sí sí esta fortaleza
está en plena campaña electoral
es una campaña electoral y está
volviendo a sus inicios de campaña de la
campaña anterior donde se dio cuenta que
lo que funcionaba era lo que está
haciendo exactamente ahora funcionaba
evolucionaron claro entonces política
antimigratoria todavía los
estadounidenses los asustan con esta
inmigración peligrosa que está entonces
está volviendo a la misma retórica
porque se da cuenta de que con la
economía sola es decir que no hay un
gran desempleo en eeuu tal vez no le
alcance entonces es eso lo que está
sucediendo
exacto y tenías algún otro tema
me agradó muchísimo porque tiene que ver
con la educación pública y es un informe
anual que acaba de salir de unicef la
organización de los niños de las
naciones unidas en donde se hizo un
análisis con 38 solamente con 38 países
ricos
entonces entre esos países ricos lo que
analizó fue el grado de desigualdad
educativa que existen en esos países y
finalmente hace un especial hay un anexo
especial sobre canadá la situación
canadiense que la tituló el factor de
ajuste porque la educación crea equidad
infantil en canadá donde destaca el rol
de la radio pública canadiense en
justamente aclaran que hay cada vez una
mayor desigualdad también en canadá a
nivel económica y una derecha pero que
es justamente la educación pública en la
que logra hacer que esas esa brecha de
desigualdad económica
se note y que sirva para igualarlos en
las escuelas públicas entonces es una
noticia que me alegró muchísimo porque
todo lo que es público parece que suena
mal estos días no que sea salud pública
educación pública pero tampoco
subvencionado o menos subvencionado que
ya lo estuvieron antes no todos estos
sectores como es esta época del
neoliberalismo pues entonces si hay una
tendencia más a privatizar todo y la
educación es parte de ese desde ese
proyecto de privatizar y lo que hablamos
con david morley que es un representante
de unicef canadá y él decía que tiene un
cierto temor justamente en eso de que
las escuelas públicas pues viven de los
impuestos y cada vez hay más un empuje a
que así que a disminuir los impuestos y
si disminuyen los impuestos sobre todo
los ricos a las compañías pues esos
impuestos son los que hacen vivir a las
escuelas públicas entonces me pareció
muy interesante la noticia
aunque en colombia están aumentando los
impuestos el 9 el presidente electo está
aumentando los impuestos del oliva y le
quiere reducir a los ricos a las
empresas pero
rumbo al enfriar sobre este tema uno de
los temas centrales uno de los de las
columnas centrales del neoliberalismo es
justamente eliminar la educación pública
y eso por ejemplo lo explica de vos la
armh england la que sería la ministra de
educación en eeuu una multimillonaria
cuya fortuna ha sido justamente
prestando tener estudiantes
y desde esa perspectiva esto de tener
una escuela pública es anatema contra
los principios del neoliberalismo que ni
siquiera es liberalismo a la manera de
adam smith que hablaba de la libre
competencia es todo lo contrario lo que
me llama la atención no sé si alguna
música de horror o de bode o de
halloween es justamente este este este
este este halloween político que vivimos
en estos días justamente porque en una
especie de este zombi político de la
derecha que es john bolton acaba de
anunciar nuevas sanciones contra cuba
también acaba de amenazar a nicaragua y
dice que el objetivo es combatir estas
dictaduras en venezuela en cubo de
nicaragua y por ejemplo va a dice que
managua sentir a todo el peso de los
robustos régimen de sanciones de eeuu y
declaró también que tanto iván duque de
colombia como el mandatario de brasil
yair volcaron son líderes
y que van a tratar de buena es la
doctrina entendiendo la cama básicamente
es la doctrina monroe de américa sólidos
conoce la extraña barack obama no en
este momento era tan criticado también
pero en este momento me acuerdo
justamente cuando él inició un
acercamiento con castró y con cuba y
finalmente había como una especie de
alegría en la región al decir bueno se
van a normalizar las relaciones no claro
y sobre todo este cínico oportunismo de
usar las instituciones internacionales
como la onu john bolton por ejemplo fue
el que estuvo detrás de esta triste
mente célebre capsulita de que el pobre
a colin powell mostrando naciones unidas
que con este frasquito irak tenía armas
de seducción masiva y lo invadieron ese
fue el pretexto para invadir exactamente
john bolton está detrás de esto y
también es ese y esto justamente al día
siguiente de que 189 países condenan el
embargo contra cuba pero eeuu siempre se
presenta como el portavoz de la opinión
de la
comunidad internacional así que pues eso
es un verdadero halloween es una fiesta
son zombies políticos los que están
manejando la política tercera del mundo
muy bien javier yo sé que hace muy poco
que estás acá en montreal que ha llegado
por acá por estos lares pero de lo que
has visto desde que ha llegado aquí a
montar tu me decías que es la segunda
vez que estás aquí y hay algo que te
haya atraído la atención en estos días
me gusta como observador trabajo si
bueno veo que hay una comunidad
latinoamericana fuerte un cosa que me da
muchísimo gusto
estamos representados aquí varios países
del continente nada más en esta mesita
por ejemplo mañana voy a participar con
unos compañeros míos mexicanos en un
espectáculo grande y esta es la razón de
tu visitas es una de las razones una de
las razones han sido muy fraternales
conmigo pero regreso a tu pregunta
hay una comunidad artística sana fuerte
que me da gusto que suceda así porque no
sucede en otros lugares del planeta por
lo mismo que estaban ustedes diciendo yo
no voy a hablar de política yo vengo con
la guitarra estoy completamente de
acuerdo con todo lo que dijeron ustedes
y en méxico está pasando un proceso muy
delicado en este momento sí sí entonces
bueno tenemos que aprender a hacer
ajedrecistas creo que la historia nos
enseñó ya corrió mucha sangre ya tuvimos
muchos mártires creo que es el momento
de empezar a ser el partido más cerebral
para ya ganarlo
pero le quitaré el súper política en la
que la historia martínez escrita en
canciones y guitarras
es parte de nuestra naturaleza
fundamental
y javier cuéntanos un poco esa guitarra
cómo llegaste tú a la guitarra o como la
guitarra llego a ti ya lo voy a decir
con mucho orgullo y creo que va a ser en
plural porque muy probablemente le
sucedió a ustedes también yo no busqué a
la guitarra la guitarra ya estaba ahí
cuando yo me di cuenta tenemos una
cultura guitarrística muy fuerte en toda
latinoamérica
entonces tanto en casa de mis abuelos
paternos como en casa de mis abuelos
maternos había una guitarra yo no la
busqué es un rayo ahí estaba yo la tomé
escuchaba algo a mis tíos enamorados y
que se encerraban a tocar la guitarra y
esa fue mi primera escuela y después
curso de agronomía había yo vengo de una
familia de clase media baja y había que
cursar una carrera que fuera productiva
en adelante como que siempre los papás
lo han visto con temor en la universidad
de chapingo del actual muy orgulloso de
que grecia es una universidad pública
con especialidad en sociología son las
amigas
si está a buenas afueras de la ciudad de
méxico está ya ese estado de méxico y
ese estado porque por su vocación
agronómica requiere de extensiones
grandes para los campos experimentales
digamos que con sociología rural mucho
dinero no vas a hacer pero el trabajo
desde cero que están al ver la cara de
mi papá hicimos un grupo musical en la
universidad que funcionó muy bien
entonces él de pronto yo estaba tocando
las 3 de la mañana en una reunión para
un profesor que a las 7 de la mañana iba
a intentar reprobar me en un examen es
un fue un dilema muy fuerte pesó más la
música nos fuimos a cancún en una
aventura tratando de conseguir el amor
por la economía pesó más la música que
la formó la economía por la sociología
por la economía y bueno esas historias
nunca son color de rosa
cuál es la de la sociología la de llegar
como grupo musical a intentar ganar la
vida como músicos
entonces llegamos a cancún no fue fácil
el grupo se desintegró y yo empecé a
trabajar como solista y de alguna forma
me estabilice
entonces empecé yo ya traía algunas
ideas con la guitarra de composición de
letras incluso en varios de sus discos
no hay más que la guitarra en los
últimos ya ha habido una situación en
que hemos podido incluir más
instrumentos pero los primeros son
austeros el formato más austero para
hacer música es con este bellísimo
instrumento y tam tam y en las primeras
grabaciones eso es lo que hay
pero por el otro lado es exquisito
porque esto es una pequeña orquesta
entonces bueno entonces empecé a grabar
y cancún me ha servido como es una
ventana de méxico hacia el exterior y de
ahí me ha servido para irme a sumar a
otros lados como en este momento que me
da muchísimo gusto estar compartiendo
esta mesa con ustedes son compañeros muy
cultos me da muchísimo depende de la
hora
[Risas]
que nos gusta que nos fuerte en con
flores javier y te gustaría interpretar
nos algo necesitamos algo corto digamos
un minuto por minuto y medio nada más
que una versión express es una canción
de estilo
de tu mano de tu mano
bueno
y
a
i
[Música]
[Risas]
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la canción de tu mano hermoso hermoso y
esa composición tuya es una pieza que
dura como 6 minutos pero ahorita son un
extracto así de lo que son los temas la
idea principal
bueno bueno y continuamos entonces acá
con nuestro castor y en una excelente
compañía a leonardo gimeno gente que nos
saludan bueno mindfreak echeverría nos
hace un delito a la riva tan sab
césar rodríguez harry que buena ya tiene
saludo desde colombia de nuestro buen
amigo de rodríguez tal y seguí tarrasa
gran amigas guitarras sociológicas y
tierras rurales guitarras cancunense
saludos desde bogotá luis balderas dicen
muchos saludos del equipo de radio 40
nacional y como siempre los lentos de
san antonio el primer puerto de chile
abrazo se repite con cena nuera y me
gusta escuchar ibérica no queda nada en
las américas porque aprende y reflexiona
los comentarios hacen que hacen todos
ustedes feliz día de los muertos amigos
del castor cibernético así que bueno
esos son los saludos de la gente que nos
está sintoniza
cierto se nos había olvidado ayer fue el
día de muertos y hoy es todos los santos
de méxico la tradición que es
prehispánica es el 2 de noviembre
el de todos los santos de mañana
con las fiestas así como que nos
confundimos pero bueno de todas maneras
resaltamos ese hecho y mandamos un
saludo a todos los que festejan es el
día de los muertos y el día de los
santos de todos los años un saludo a
todos los santos ya todos aquellos que
bueno antes de entrar en la lectura de
nuestros comentarios de los oyentes de
los otros comentarios
yo les quería decir que algo lo que me
llamó la atención fíjate que aquí en
este país siempre ahí hay cosas que
aunque lleva 145 años siempre hay algo
que te sorprende
esta vez lo que me sorprendió fue una
noticia que vi en nuestro sitio de radio
canadá a lo mejor tú lo puedes localizar
leonardo en radio canadá es de una
cárcel que está en venta una cárcel del
dólar
no sé pero es una venta como se dice en
los remates un remate un remate no
quiere decir que empieza con comienza
por un dólar y después entonces se va
porque yo pensaba el mejor portón sé que
podía encontrarla por un don bueno sino
de la acera y habitaciones para
estudiantes pero si no hay quien pague
más
pero en oficio porque ese edificio pues
es un viejo edificio que fue construido
en 1924 muy sólido y que bueno pero
además de la cárcel de la propiedad como
tal que se encuentra en el barrio old
sandwich de windsor ontario está además
de la cárcel hay un
ya sé que me encantó ese edificio que
todo es parte del conjunto es más de la
cárcel y bueno pues esa cárcel como
decíamos fue construida en 1924 y desde
entonces pues hace parte del patrimonio
del sandwich
y fue designado justamente en el 2012 se
le dio a una compañía para que haga el
remate justamente no sé si lo
encontraste sl o en todo caso es un
edificio muy bonito si vas a insólitos
en radio canadá ahí está
otra de las cosas es que se dice dentro
de las historias alrededor de esta
cárcel es que bueno tiene unos muros de
cementos que miden 20 metros de altura
entonces para escaparse de ahí bueno no
se ha notificado ningún escape pero
incluso si se intenta ahí está la cárcel
para los de ellos
yo había edificio que me había llamado
la atención y que es muy muy interesante
muy lindo ves ya no parece una cárcel
para nada va a haber sido la oficina de
los jefes
sí pero el carcelero imagínate el
carcelero muerto de la risa y pues si
los oyentes quieren tener experiencia
carcelaria en canadá a lo mejor es ir a
ottawa así porque allí el hostal de lo
está en la ciudad es una antigua cárcel
y yo dormía y esto y te da unas par de
sábanas y almohadas y claramente duermes
en las casas de estar los barrotes de
las celdas
en ese lugar fue donde se va a cabo la
última la última ejecución pública en
grada con el asesino tras el asesinato
de un político aquí estoy
dos mil ochocientos y pico y él dicen
que su fantasma anda por qué es una es
una presión fantástica no se toma muy
bien porque hay gente que ronca pero en
fin a los muros entre una celda y otra
me imagino no sé no no son son como este
espacio
hay dos camas y pues son son amplias en
comparación a las nuevas cárceles que
son más más pequeñas pero no funcionaron
a ni sí pero son muy obliga son muy
tristes bueno si es el carácter mismo de
la cárcel divierta y no está con arabia
saudita que dejar sedes el hotel de
cinco estrellas bueno yo dormí dos veces
según la cárcel los amigos presos que
tomás de pensar y decir diciéndome que
dormita en la cárcel de ottawa me hace
recordar qué
dos veces en una cárcel una vez en perú
en un pueblito saliendo de bolivia
justamente íbamos en el carro no bueno
hubo un incidente y terminamos de la
cárcel y vamos ya estaba con un grupo de
canadienses
el grupo decanation de canadienses
derecho que conocí en bolivia y con el
cual vine acá a canadá y bueno con una
de las integrantes de ese grupo y
entonces pues hubo tuvimos un incidente
y no pusieron presos igual entonces nos
cerraron en la cárcel salvo que será un
día de fiesta en el pueblo clásico pero
entonces el carcelero policía que estaba
ahí que bien estaba encartado con
nosotros porque no se esperaba tener
detenidos y no habían así que no había
nadie en la cárcel ese día le dicen buen
trago con un detenido gringo pues salvo
en mi persona no entonces
se oía la música en el pueblo y todo eso
eso fue a finales del medio al final del
día como a las 5 de la tarde y como a
las 7 de la noche se prendió la música y
la fiesta en el pueblo y en una de esas
el policía viene a vernos y nos dice
bueno vamos a hacer una cosa yo no me
quiero perder la fiesta así de que
vengan conmigo y que no se me escape del
carro vivo la llave del carro y nos
fuimos con el señor
pero sí sí y la pasamos de lo más rico y
lo cómico y lo curioso y que me daba
mucha risa y me da mucha risa
aún al contarlo es que
mi mujer que estaba en ese momento que
estaba que acompañaba mi proyecto de
esposa en este momento está éramos
novios entonces en un momento dado
quería quería ir al baño y le dice al
policía me da la llave del cuarto por
vos
[Música]
acostumbrado a ir de este hotel ego te
pido fue muy curioso bueno y lo traje
fue en barranquilla en aquella época de
hippies no se fumaba mucha marihuana
colombiano
bueno yo en aquella época así ahora no
siempre en contravía entonces resulta
eso fue 18 de diciembre fiesta de las
velitas en barra aquí estaba con unos
amigos gringos justamente dos años
después y resulta de que teníamos un
tabaco de marihuana y nos paró la
policía
estaba quito marihuana nos pusieron
preso pasamos la noche del 8 y siempre
que es así era una gran fiesta que no me
quería perder y entonces esas fueron las
únicas veces que me tocó dormir en la
casa del prisionero en perú
donde el día de fiesta y el pueblito
chiquito bueno y encadenamos con los
mensajes que tenemos por ahí anda es que
hay mensajes en el de nuestros oyentes
juan carlos miranda duarte dice hola
también nos saluda vía facebook así que
un saludo grande para el que nos está
sintonizando en este momento bueno si si
no tengo aquí
un comentario sobre lópez obrador
analiza la legalización de drogas como
oposición como opción se llevarán a ton
basificar méxico dice aquí primero hay
que corregir la desigualdad social y
económica es decir reducir la gran
pobreza que existe en méxico y creo que
el principal problema con
respecto a las drogas es evitar en gran
medida la producción de los derivados de
la anfetamina
es decir la droga llamada crystal que es
la que provoca una adicción muy
dependiente al grado que quien cae en
esta adicción llega a robar para calmar
sus necesidades de droga aquí en méxico
está muy arriesgado este tipo de
adicción arraigado perdón principalmente
en los adolescentes al grado que se ha
hecho un problema social muy grave es
javier gonzález lugar hay quien nos
comenta esta noticia
leonora si tengo acá un comentario de el
español y los adultos mayores en canadá
que es una producción de rufo dice gira
y escribe y dice muchas gracias por el
reportaje me parece especialmente
interesante el enfoque y las entrevistas
y en respuesta a gira y escribe el juan
carlos en respuesta a gira y dice
coincido contigo juan carlos es de
sorprenderse saber este dato histórico
de la lengua muy bien es un mensaje de
carla que dice reacciona a un reportaje
o noticia que indicaba que las
profesiones con salarios más elevados
y canadá están en la provincia de
alberta y cara dice la verdad por eso la
verdad por eso es tan importante
prepararse bien para el futuro con
maestrías en línea gratis se puede hacer
realmente son muy buenas y recomendadas
saludos diseño bueno y acá tengo un
mensaje de primas cuando la esperanza y
la voluntad superan el horror creo que
fue una entrevista que hizo paloma es
sobre un documental de unas chicas
argentinas si no me equivoco y cambie la
lente documental sí y camila dice que
bien por las tres han ganado con el film
tanta fuerza y espíritu para salir
adelante felicitaciones por todo lo
logrado y que sigan por este camino con
coraje y alegría además la directora si
no me equivoco es la tía de una de estas
niñas que es la historia es contada
durante el documental y la otra historia
es justamente de una prima de esta niña
son las dos historias que se van que son
el limón gergen el santo y niñas que
habían sido abusadas es un abusada otras
bueno entonces pues ese era el
comentario de la parte de camila y
regresemos a javier a ver javier que nos
vas a interpretar ahora esto se llama
olas
que
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
[Música]
javier entonces tú decías que la razón
por la cual una de las razones por la
cual es que vas a participar en un
espectáculo aquí con un grupo de
mexicanos dpt acá el día de muerte nos
están escuchando quiero mandar un
fraternal saludo a mis compañeros del
grupo los vieja en especial a mi hermano
marino vázquez que hemos compartido el
pan hemos ganado el sustento allá en
cancún por años y aquí como invitado
son amigos tuyos claro que sí me
comentaron a nosotros este eso entonces
y al ballet mexicano de montreal que es
fabuloso porque son muchos están
haciendo mucho la danza folklórica
mexicana que es tan bella entonces todo
eso lo van a ver mañana
en la noche en el auditorio de la ucam
este invita dijimos todo el auditorio
que nos está escuchando y yo voy a hacer
una participación pequeña hay textos
esteban a hablar de la tradición del día
de muertos en méxico los sabores de la
comida y todo eso
y hay intervenciones del grupo muy bien
hecha se han ensayado bastante y me
están acompañando en vivo al ballet y en
los pasajes sin que se habla me pidieron
que haga yo guitarra que los arrolló
exactamente es una palabra en el envase
hacer comunión de la palabra con la
guitarra saque la guitarra vaya acorde
con lo que se está diciendo con el texto
si es algo un poco melancólico si es
algo amoroso si es algo de comida que ya
me lo dijeron que me pidieron incluso
una pieza que sea un poco más rural
bueno todo eso a ver allí imitadísimo
limitadísimos es una pregunta justamente
la tradición negra fia de muertos como
tú decías tiene raíces en la antigüedad
antes de que llegan los los europeos en
ese sentido en la música que tú tocas se
nutre de elementos indígenas hay ritmos
indígenas en la música que tú haces que
bonita pregunta definitivamente si como
lo hay en mi sangre como la gente en mi
pueblo pues mi cultura
tenemos un rato muy típico alguna vez lo
han probado es el mole voy a responder a
responder
con estas palabras el mole es mestizo
por excelencia porque lleva semillas de
muchos lados pero su base es el maíz y
el cacao y el chile pero de todas formas
tiene ajonjolí que no es nuestro tiene
otras ingredientes que llevaron ahí que
le pusieron que que no son de nuestra
cultura sino que llegaron como también
esta sangre ya no está tampoco
completamente pura sino que estamos
mezclados y que yo creo que ese es el
futuro de la humanidad
entonces respondo a tu pregunta los
elementos que hay en estas cuando yo me
pongo a hacer un trabajo de composición
en primer lugar yo soy todo de sacar lo
que traigo en el alma sí estoy
enamoradísimos y estoy bien contento si
estoy bien triste si perdí un ser
querido que la vida no es color de rosa
y a la hora de hacer eso inevitablemente
uso los elementos que tuve a mano desde
que tomen la guitarra de la casa de mis
abuelos como lo podrías haber hecho tú o
ella este y esos elementos son mestizos
por excelencia porque es nuestra cultura
no sé si el caso a responder
hay elementos por ejemplo la guitarra
del abuelo la recuerdo muy bien porque
es una guitarra muy rancherita ya como
la gran edad en el rancho grande
es este sonido los músicos decimos en
sextas pero que es muy de pueblito y sin
embargo después vuelves a escuchar la
música clásica me encanta el jazz me
encanta la música latinoamericana la
música caribeña la música cubana
entonces a la hora de componer estás
enamoradísimo no estás pensando si lo
vas a hacer con todos que dije
simplemente estás enamoradísimo pero con
que el lenguaje lo vas a decir con el
con el bagaje que ya traes puesto en la
camiseta del amor no existe existe las
pruebas del amor que son las canciones
el tiempo entre los dedos nos quedan
diez mil nueve minutos entonces gramos
vamos a entrar muy rápidamente en los
temas que vamos a resaltar para hoy
leonora tú nos resalta es un debate
desatado por steve steve evans
sí un poco continuando lo con el
halloween como dijo
zombies en estos momentos dentro de una
hora más o menos en toronto a ello se va
a llevar a cabo un debate un
controvertido controvertido debate por
la presencia justamente
estadounidense steve banon que fue un
jefe de noticias de ultraderecha en eeuu
no sé si fue la mano derecha también de
momento dado de trump hacia los inicios
de la presidencia él fue el que está el
origen para que tengan una idea está el
origen de esta prohibición de que
lleguen a eeuu musulmanes de 6 países
por ejemplo que trump adoptó esa medida
fue él el que estaba detrás es muy anti
inmigración entre otras cosas y fue
invitado aquí a un debate en la escuela
mont-blanc y entonces eso generó pues
una oleada de protestas y no en canadá
es sobre la pertinencia de invitar a un
personaje de esta naturaleza político
ante los blogs ya dijimos y entonces
como que eso también creó una especie de
debate los que están a favor de la
libertad de expresión incluso con
personas como banon y los que dicen que
directamente no tienen que darle la
tribuna ni el micrófono a ningún
ninguna persona con estas
características entonces hay una
coalición de organismos comunitarios en
canadá que se han reunido en esta
ocasión y yo conversé con una persona de
este organismo nadie es ilegal en
toronto que están participando y hoy en
estos momentos se llevan a cabo una
manifestación en toronto bastante grande
con estudiantes universitarios también
sindicalistas donde quieren impedir dis
no no pueden impedirlo pero entonces
están demostrando que mientras ya no
están contentos con la presencia de este
señor en vano aquí en canadá muy bien lo
que quieran tener más detalles
rcn punto ce a ruffo valencia tú nos
dices que canadá planea deportar
anualmente 10.000 extranjeros y
solicitantes de refugio que han sido
rechazados y justamente estas de esta
cuesta este tema porque es quiérase o no
un eco de lo que está pasando en eeuu de
esta oleada anti anti inmigrante
entonces en canadá la derecha canadiense
ha estado atacando constantemente al
gobierno federal al gobierno libras de
justin foto
sobre el tema de inmigración indicando
que son débiles que no están haciendo
una crisis debido a los inmigrantes que
están llegando a través de puntos no
oficiales entonces esa media y como
estamos siendo lecciones justamente el
gobierno ha determinado elevar entre un
25 a un 35 por ciento el porcentaje de
personas que van a ser deportadas
entonces para tener media realmente y
concluir en el en el 2012 se habían
deportado 18 mil 987 personas era la
época de stephen jones bajo stephen
harper en 2017 es decir así el año
pasado el número cayó a 8 mil 472 y
ahora vamos a subir a los 10.000
expulsados y esto solamente por pura
pues para los críticos en un puro
posesionamiento político rumbo a las
próximas elecciones federales en que
nada hay que decir solamente quiero
agregar un poquito porque esto es
materia de reflexión también lo que está
lo que está presentando aquí rufo es que
canadá está cada vez más aislado en el
continente con este tema
todos los refugiados y de la inmigración
cuando ya tenemos macri en argentina que
están y quieren implementar endurecer la
mano justamente y expulsar a extranjeros
está bolsonaro que promete también
llevar a cabo la misma política y está
trump entonces hay como un hay una
conclusión dentro de este espacio es el
único que todavía está a favor de la
inmigración y está a favor de los
refugiados también justamente de sus
servicios elementos tiempo del fascismo
ese es un signo ok el leonardo gimeno tú
nos hablas de facebook de público más
joven y de centennial bueno es el tiempo
importan los milenios y los entendidos
son los más chiquititos todavía que el
tema son aquellos que van hasta los 16
años aproximadamente y que está nacieron
con una cultura digital que están
acostumbrados a esto y que no les daba
la atención les daba la atención
nuestros viejos televisores el teléfono
con el estadístico ese tipo de cosas que
sí hizo qué es
bueno efectivamente esa es digamos el
segmento etáreo que facebook pierde
sigue sin poder reclutar gente en esas
edades entonces lo que está tratando de
hacer es emular una aplicación que tuvo
mucho éxito entre los jóvenes entre
jóvenes y adolescentes que se llama musa
musical y que en realidad ahora está no
es más llamativo que fue comprada por
una empresa china está bien entonces
luego hacer facebook básicamente es
emular esta aplicación para atraer al
público joven y a ese público joven
quien los atrae en esa gran música
personas sociales otras redes sociales
que están en competencia con pacific &
son creadas para ello también hay
algunas que desean especialmente
dedicadas a ese público que no haya
creado algo especial no tuvo nunca éxito
con los jóvenes jóvenes ahora está
haciendo otra vez si tuviera más de los
millones ganados está muy bien yo por mi
parte lo quiero invitar a escuchar una
entrevista que hice ayer justamente con
un gran director de cine mexicano que se
llama
amat escalante amat escalante está en
este momento aquí en montreal él fue
invitado por el cinema moderna un cinema
nuevo que una sala de cine nueva que fue
creada hace un mes más o menos y tiene
una serie de retrospectivas y comenzaron
con la retrospectiva de amat escalante
que amat escalante pues se encuentra
entre los grandes directores de cine de
méxico y lo ponen a la misma altura que
alfonso cuarón que el yermo del toro y
que y que los otros con alejandro
gonzález iñárritu y carlos reygadas
entonces pc se presenta este fin de
semana en una serie de películas que
hizo escalante entre ellos la última
película de escalante que se llama la
región salvaje entonces pues los invito
a visitar nuestro sitio internet y nos
vamos a despedir con javier
y te agradecemos de paso javier tu
presencia aquí en este estudio
muchísimas gracias por haber aceptado la
invitación un honor estar a compartir
con ustedes estos micrófonos y les dejo
mi sitio www.hardrock.com punto mx yo lo
voy a poner en la mira ya pueden
encontrarme en las plataformas de
descarga de música y ahí ya están ahí mi
disco y vamos a despedirnos por esto que
se llama en que bueno mientras tanto
pues eleonora rufo leonardo muchísimas
gracias y agradecemos también a nuestra
técnica hoy chantal 6 over y le mandamos
un saludo a una cierta y útil las y ya
los amigos de prisma arroyo
bueno
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]